you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from the 1971 candidates final
around seven game between Bobby Fischer
on the wide end in Tigran Petrosian so
it would be the winner of this match
that would go on to challenge Boris
Spassky for the world title I was
playing a slower game recently and I was
reminded of this move 22 by Fischer in
this game this surprising moved 22 it
was Fischer's idea in this game that
helped let's say give me the confidence
to execute an idea in my own game can
sometimes be difficult to let's say
break certain rules so let's dive in and
see how this one plays out opening wise
we have in an open Sicilian Kahn
variation aside from this move 22 talk
there are other instructional moments in
this game if you're looking for a good
game that demonstrates how to take
advantage of weak pawns isolated pawns
in a fairly simplified position this one
gets my vote now from here we have the
line move 5 Bishop d3 against the con
this Knight now unprotected is
challenged white takes black taking
towards the center looks to establish a
strong point d5 so this point is
challenged defense series of exchanges
and important moment is this move 10 how
to recapture on d5 the suggestions by
the engine says take with the queen of
the night or in other words play within
the structure you can see how a human
would quickly let's say dismiss Queen
takes d5 because of the development with
tempo let's just have a peek at Knight
takes d5 what would maybe keep a black
from playing Knight takes d5 well there
can be some ensuing pressure against
Knight who's now in a pen and it may be
the case that white can force onto black
in isolated pond and even have some more
peace exchanges in the process so the
idea here with move 10 let's just take
on the isolated pawn
let's just play with some more minor
pieces on the board the Queen's on the
board at least for this moment okay from
here we have some more development and
another thing now that black has this
isolated pond what would be a desirable
exchange for white does anything come to
mind for you feel free to pause the
video and find an answer to that
question okay anyhow I'm just going to
share some thoughts of mine I think a
dark square Bishop exchange would be
desirable for white and the reason for
this this pawn would like to be able to
move one day and the number one minor
piece that's going to help out with that
is the dark square Bishop it's a very
good supporter of a d4 advance and in an
ideal world what white would like to
have happen is a dark square Bishop
exchange and then this Knight right here
blockading that isolated pawn that
passed pawn and you'll find that this
knight on d4 without dark square bishop
signboard will be much easier to
maintain won't need a babysitter over
the d4 Knight this guy won't be around
to put pressure on it okay
anyhow we have something to look forward
to that's what I'm getting at a dark
square bishop exchange look we're
playing as white now Queen a4 check is
met with Queen d7 may be tempting to
play Bishop d7 it's a top suggestion by
the engine a reason to maybe not do this
white ducks puts the Queen on d4 and
says aha now your major piece has to
defend a6 and I only have a minor piece
putting pressure on it that may cause an
imbalance elsewhere
the bishop I feel will be the most
efficient defender of a six I think the
bishop would stand well patrolling that
main diagonal okay with blacks move 12
Queen d7 this is not only there to offer
a queen exchange but also offering the
exchange what am I talking about
move thirteen what does Fischer play
next and also how can white win some
material okay here we go in the game
which rook to e1
how can Fischer win some material
well Bishop to b5 a skewer you would
have to take the bishop in order to save
the Queen and there you go white can win
a rook for a bishop now why does Fischer
not go for this well I guess a matter of
taste preferring a much more controlled
position a simp much more simplistic
position static position this one is
dynamic this one would be dynamic if the
white is going for this material why
well the knight is unstable it can be
kicked with d4 b4 I'm thinking d4 at
some point would hit opening up one day
the bishop size to g2 where does the
knight go it gets messy now you've
stared a computer evaluation it's gonna
love this position for white not so easy
however two humans going at it
in short Fischer's going for something
static rook to e1 something much more
controlled Queens are exchanged it
should be six guess where this guy's
headed III now just one move away from a
dark square bishop exchange in this
position black castles suggestion by the
engine is to fight off this Bishop to c5
move fight off the knight that's on a
four
this game it's castles Bishop c5 dark
square Bishop exchange what to do from
here move 18 is very instructive move 18
sets the stage for an eventual Zuke's
long black is going to have some blacks
can have to enter a our blacks going to
be in a very awkward position let's just
say because of this next decision by
Fischer
what is this decision feel free to pause
the video okay here we go you ready
b4 now what's the story with the B form
how tempting it might be right - let's
say move a knight forward in blacks
house and you're throwing a punch but
black can simply play a 5 and say what
are you staring at now nothing the idea
with b4 is to fix a weak pawn on a6 now
not in the most direct sense to fix the
pawn on a6 but at least say this much
if you move there's a cost in that cost
is you have given me a passed pawn white
will reply with b5 so it is first b4 and
only then Knight c5 this will now cause
black to bend over backwards under
developing with Bishop to ca has to now
babysit this week pawn on a6 again this
all started because of this one key move
b4 let's see how this kind of snowballs
into something much more serious for
black f3 nice
purpose move control the night and how
great that would be how great it would
be to have the king on d4 there's now a
path onto that strong central square
rook a seven for the moment putting both
major pieces on a six so that this
Bishop can reroute somewhere else
rookie five Bishop d7 in here we are
move 22 a surprising moment in this game
this next decision by Fischer is one
that had several grandmasters talking in
the press room and Miguel nide Worf even
claiming that it was a mistake well it
wasn't a mistake it was a move that
would well allow the white rooks to
become very active this next decision
allows the white rooks to enter blacks
position very easily now what is this
move well feel free to pause the video
what does Fischer do next okay here we
go
Knight takes Bishop now why is this so
surprising well generally speaking the
bishop is better than the knight but not
in this position the knight is superior
to the bishop
it's unchallenged by any black pawns
these pawns interfere with the bishops
mobility taking the bishop in this
position is allowing these weak pawns to
be more accessible to the white rooks so
we can you see how black now gets tied
down rook c1 rooks e7 the threat here
was to get to rook c6 so black is
defending that this rook is defending
both weak pawns but giving up the
seventh rank it's now occupied and the
threat is to get the other look here
that would be too much to deal with
black goes backwards just to interfere
with rookie 7 also throws a punch
rookie 2 and now notice this position
move 18 was B for right and we have a
series of and we had some backward moves
some defensive moves a 6 has the
attention of the black pieces what does
black do here if the knight moves the
brook gets to the seventh if the rook
moves the night falls what about this
rook if it goes to this square
it's not even threatening b4 y can take
a six and say you take my bishop I take
your knight you take my pawn I'm gonna
give checkmate what else is there well
let's say a rook exchange that's really
not going to help black will still have
to go on the defensive and there's
forward progress for white to make
working with the two-to-one majority
this guys pass but going nowhere
what does black have to do there's only
King King side pawn moves for black
that's what we have it these next
handful of moves g6
King f2 h5 f for fixing this pawn on a
light square maybe looking to one day
expand like an inch his way up with g3
h3g for maybe one day getting up on here
taking away a square from a knight
there's way to ways to improve for white
H for is now mat with King F for looking
to simply pick up the bond this causes
another concession in blacks camp some
more weaknesses f5 keeps the King out of
g4 but this square is now maybe
something you know a square that white
can occupy at some stage if this rook
goes elsewhere
from here King III I like these little
this little maneuver by the king luring
the black pawns forward weaknesses are
now created white just now a moment away
from Greta getting to this strong post
on d4 that shot down at the same time
notice the weakness that is created on
c4 a new possibility is now present for
the bishop now from here we have Knight
to b6 which is allowing the white rook
to get to e7 and it's really gonna be
painful for black some other try besides
Knight to b6 I'm not sure what to
suggest let's have a look at rook to b8
if ruk to b8 is played Y can play Bishop
to c4 immediately making use of that
weakness after the d4 move this pawn is
poison this would lead to a mate in
three one way or the other that's me and
if you go here that's me let's say rook
b8 Bishop c4 and something else I'm not
sure what that something else is even
the rook can't go too far we have this
we can exchange rooks route to a7 and
again we've basically seen a position
like this before where you know two to
one majority and the Queen side white is
even closer in this scenario with
gobbling up this pawn if this rook goes
elsewhere black is totally on their back
foot in this position what is try is
Knight b6 rook e2 e7
there's a fork but there's a way out
with the check rook to b7 this Knight is
a long way off from
threatening either rook and yeah we have
mate threats nearby Bishop c4 move 34 is
the final move of this game black
resigns what do you do here there's
multiple winning ideas for white the
simple ID after Bishop to c4 is to
offset the knight not even allow it to
get to any of these two squares to let's
say try and defend on f8 and white is
just a moment away from playing rook h7
Turek h8 not a good solution to that so
for example let's just say rook here you
can just come over like this something
else you can also give check like this
King d8 and then rook h7 there's just no
good solution to the roof getting to the
8th ranked Knight here right away you
can give check and simply win a piece so
again no way to prevent the loss of
material black resigns at this stage so
an instructive game to be sure aside
from this surprising move 22 exchanging
a strong night for a bad Bishop Bishop
that was completely on the defensive
these points with b-form playing against
the isolated pawn welcoming the dark
square bishop exchange this eventually
led to a position where black regardless
of what move was played would have to
concede something anyhow as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care bye
you